in fact while people are coming in let
me just do a little poll okay cuz it's
really handy to know what kind of people
in the room so can you do me a quick
hands up if you feel that you've heard
of Blaser before and I've got some kind
of concept of what this thing is meant
to be about like like alright that's
like 90 odd percent of people very good
and what's also really interesting for
me is hands up if you've actually tried
it in some way if like run some blazer
related curd yeah that's a lot less but
there's still a good number of you okay
excellent
so just for anyone who's not familiar
with this what blazer is is it is a
framework for building rich web UI on
dotnet and I'm someone who works and
that my name is Steve and I work at
Microsoft I'm on the asp net core team
and we've been working on this for about
two years now and if you want to know
what we're going to be doing in this
talk for the next hour let me set your
expectations for the first 15 minutes
maybe 20 minutes or so we're going to be
looking at some of the the core concepts
of Blazer the what the programming model
itself actually is and hopefully for
people who have not seen it before that
I'll bring you along and get you up to
speed very quickly and then you'll
understand where we are today with the
Blazer framework and then after we've
done that we're going to move on and see
some slightly more advanced things I
want to spend about 20 minutes to maybe
half an hour showing you some features
that we're working on at the moment
things that we haven't shipped but we
think they're exciting and they're going
to make this even better so I'm
hopefully gonna be able to show you a
few new things during that phase and
then for the last 10 15 minutes of the
talk will be casting our minds further
forwards into the future even still to
get a sense of where this thing could be
going in the long term depending on what
people want ok so to get started with
bringing everyone up to speed let me
give you a very quick history lesson ok
we're gonna step back in time to the far
distant reaches of the past way back in
2017 imagine can you remember what it
was like back in those days if you
wanted to build for yourself a rich web
application that would run in a browser
then you basically had no choice but to
use one of these kinds of things you
would be using a JavaScript based spar
framework something like angular
view or react and your programming would
be done in JavaScript or maybe you think
it wasn't JavaScript because you were
doing something else like typescript or
flow or something like that but
basically you're compiling to JavaScript
and that means that at runtime the
semantics of your application is
JavaScript semantics and all the
interesting behaviors that that entails
and that felt like that was the way it
is that's just the nature of reality
itself and it's never gonna change all
our web apps are gonna be written in
JavaScript until one day this
fascinating thing came along which is
webassembly the web assembly spec has
been around for a few years but around
the start of 2017 is when it became
supported by all the browsers and the
idea of web assembly is to provide a new
bytecode format for the web so that when
you're programming for the web you don't
necessarily have to use JavaScript but
you can use whatever kind of language or
framework or toolkit you want as long as
it can compile to web assembly then you
can run it inside a browser so that's
the idea
and back at those days early 2017 a lot
of people including myself got very
excited about this and started to think
well does that mean that somehow we
could get dotnet to run inside our
browsers and not in the old way like
Silverlight did with a plug-in but this
time just purely on native standards so
it's just gonna run everywhere on all
desktops or Mobile's it's just gonna
work because it's standard so I start
doing a little bit of prototyping of
this and I found to my surprise and
delight that very quickly yes it is
possible we can make dotnet run on web
assembly and it involves three
ingredients so the first ingredient is
web assembly itself the bytecode suppor
map bytecode format and you do need
support for that in your browser but
that's cool because all desktop and
mobile browsers that are written in the
last two years do have that support
that's great then what else do we need
well we need to take a dotnet runtime
and compile that to web assembly so that
it can run inside your browser and
that's not as hard as it sounds so I got
that working and I thought okay this is
really cool as longer as the only thing
that I ever want to do is just log stuff
to the console that's not the only thing
I wanted to do what I wanted to do was
build some rich interactive web apps and
for that
I would need a new UI framework and
that's where blazer comes onto the scene
so blazer is a UI framework it's a way
of defining the shape of your
application all the components that are
in it the way that you respond to events
and what stuff gets re-rendered all that
kind of stuff because that's running
inside your browser on webassembly
if it wants to update the UI it can just
do so directly because it's already
there it can just reach out and interact
with the Dom API to update what is
displayed inside the browser so that is
the original hosting model for blazer
and it's what we now call client-side
blazer or blazer webassembly
and that's great and we're working very
hard on that but while we were building
it we realized that we've got something
really flexible here because blazer is
not actually tied to web assembly in any
way it can actually run anywhere that
dotnet can run and so we realized that
as well as letting you run your
components inside a browser we could
also let you run them on the server this
is what we call server-side blazer and
so the idea is that we take dotnet which
is obviously able to run on the cloud in
some servers and you can run your blazer
components there in the cloud instead of
in a browser and then when you want to
update the UI in someone's browser we
can reach out over a signaler WebSocket
connection and do those updates in real
time so we'll talk a bit more later in
this talk about these different hosting
model choices and what the pros and cons
of them are but the point I want to make
at the start is just that this is a
flexible system so if you buy into the
idea of building your UI with blazer
then you get the choice to run it
wherever and whenever however you want
you can run it inside a browser on web
assembly you can run your same
components on the server you can even
switch between them dynamically or do
whatever you want it's a flexible system
okay so that's the sort of big outline
of what this kind of thing is but we
haven't really seen it yet we haven't
seen any code and I know some of you
won't have seen that code so let's bring
everyone up to speed with what I mean by
the Blazer programming model how do we
build this interactive UI and make it
show up in a web browser and for that we
need a real scenario so I was thinking
what's it what's a realistic scenario
here well how about next week you go
back to your company and you start using
Blazer the inevitable result of that is
that you'll suddenly be dramatically
more successful than ever before and
following on from that
you'll have dramatically more money than
ever before and that leads us to one of
the problems with blazer which we can
all relate to I'm sure which is what
you're going to do with all that extra
money and to solve that we're going to
need to build some software okay
presumably we need to give the money out
as bonuses to all the staff but who gets
the money and how much do they get this
is a budget allocation problem and it's
not necessarily obvious how you design a
UI for that here's a real-world example
that someone else made if you're
purchasing the humble jumbo bundle 3
call name then you get to choose where
your money goes to and you control it
with these sliders so shall we have a go
a building a UI like that and I'll be
able to illustrate you some of the
features of the Blazer programming model
as we go ok let's switch over in to my
IDE here I'm doing this in Visual Studio
on Windows but it works just the same
cross-platform on vs code on Mac or
Linux whatever you like and I have got
this application and inside my
application what I've I got well I've
got some c-sharp files I've also got
some razor files what are all those well
let's just run the code first and so we
can get a sense of what this does so if
I start this up in my browser then what
you'll see is we get something that
looks pretty much like a dashboard kind
of website now this if you haven't seen
it before is basically what you get when
you create a blank new blazer project
using the template it looks more or less
like this so it's got a few different
pages in it it's got this counter and
it's got this thing that shows you how
you can display data but I'm not really
going to focus on those because I don't
think it's super interesting and you can
go and read some of the materials online
if you want to know about that what I
want us to do is build this bonus
splitter component ok where is that in
the source code so we can start working
on it
well blazer is a component oriented UI
framework which means that your
application itself is a component all
the pages in it or components all the
things on those pages are components so
it's this big hierarchy of components
all the way down and the syntax that we
use is razor razor files each one of
these razor files is a component and in
particular we've got this one called
bonus razor and if I show you what's in
there you'll see pretty simple right now
mostly it's just this static markup
which is the same markup that's being
rendered
my page right there we've also got this
page directive at the top and that is
telling the routing system that this
component is the thing that we should
render if the you are if the user goes
to this URL of bonus which is what I am
at right here so that's why that was
rendered okay
so what do we want to do well we want to
build this budget allocation UI and it's
going to be interactive so we will want
to bring in a bit of c-sharp code and we
can do that with a code block now I know
this is pretty basic stuff for those of
you already seen it but we will move
fairly quickly and we will reach some
stuff that you probably haven't seen but
for those who don't know this is where
we can put our c-sharp code and it will
run regardless of whether we are on the
inside the browser on webassembly or
whether we're running on the server this
in this application I'm actually running
on the server but it wouldn't make any
difference let's go ahead and write a
little bit of the logic we're going to
need firstly what's the total budget
that we've got to distribute let's say
it's a million pounds or dollars
whatever million units and we want to
decide who it's going to well I've
already defined this class called budget
item which has got a name and an amount
and I'm gonna define a list of them a
few different categories that we're
going to give money to some to the
developers some to the managers and some
to the sales okay and now I want to
render some of this stuff on the UI so
as you know I can just start writing
some normal HTML markup so I'll have a
disc a div with class budget because
I've already got some Styles ready for
it and if I want to render something for
each of those budget items I can use a
normal C sharp for each loop for each
VAR item in budget items and then I can
display some markup for each one of them
and the markup that I actually want to
have looks like this so for each one I'm
going to display its name and its amount
and I'm going to format that as a
currency value with zero decimal places
okay let's see how that looks inside the
browser when I reload
you see we've now got developers manager
sales they've all got no money yet and
we want to build an editor for that so
how should we do the editor well I'd
like to do it a bit like this with the
horizontal sliders so let's put in some
standard HTML range sliders so we can
have input type equals range and for
that we have to specify what the maximum
value is that it goes up to
and I can use the razor syntax to say
that I want it to go up to a maximum
value of the total budget and we can
also specify the minimum increment
amount so we'll say it goes up in steps
of a thousand because honestly who cares
about trivial amounts of money less than
a thousand now we're now with this rich
okay
and last thing is I'm going to use a
feature of blades are called bind where
we combined the value on that input to
the item amount okay let's see if we can
now start to edit our budget okay so if
I move the sliders you'll see it does
change these budget amounts that's good
but it's not great so far there's quite
a lot of problems with it right now
one of them is that it's nearly
impossible to enter any specific amount
of money because you can't see the
number change until you let go of the
mouse so what can we do about that well
firstly I'll tell you that when you use
bind that works by listening for the
change event inside the browser and that
only fires when I let go of the mouse so
I want to use a different event instead
and I'm going to say that I'll change
the bind to listen to the on input event
which is a standard event inside
browsers and that will fire every time I
move the slider so now as I move it
you'll see these numbers are going to
update in real time that's great
okay still we've got some problems there
one of them is I can't see how much
money is left to allocate I don't I
don't know whether I've used it all up
or not so let's display how much money
is not yet allocated and I'll do that by
adding a property called remaining and
that will be computed by taking the
total budget and subtracting all of the
amounts that we have allocated and then
I want to display that on the screen so
I'm going to say will display remaining
and will format it again as a currency
value okay let's see if it's a bit
better now reload and see you'll see
we've got a million pounds remaining and
as we allocate some money the remaining
amount goes down thus great but we still
got some problems one of them is I can
allocate more money than I've even got I
can just give everyone loads of money
and then we end up with a negative
amount remaining which is ridiculous so
we need to stop that let's make sure
that you can't allocate more money than
you've actually got how are we going to
do it well let's start with changing the
maximum amount that you are allowed to
get
so previously you can give the total
budget to each amount but let's change
that and we'll say that the maximum
amount you can give to each thing is the
amount that you've already given to it
plus the remaining amount which makes
sense right you've already got this
amount allocated and then there's this
much remaining so that's how far you're
allowed to move the slider let's see how
things behave now shall we
so I'll reload and we'll now see that as
I a liqu eight loads of money to the
developers so there's not much money
left let's see if I want to give some
money to managers then even if I move
that all the way up to the top they only
get 193 because that's all the amount
that was left and there's no money left
all right now so I can't even move the
slider for the salespeople so that's a
bit of an improvement but honestly it's
still really bizarre because these two
sliders on the right are in exactly the
same place so you it looks like they
should have the same amount of money but
they don't they've got different amounts
of money just because of what order I
move them in which is insane so what can
I do to make this thing make a bit more
sense
well the basic problem right now is that
each of these sliders represents a
different horizontal scale amount so
what I need to do to fix this is change
the horizontal scale dynamically and
this is a bit of a weird trick that
might not be obvious and you might not
even fully make sense of it even when
you see the code but hopefully you'll
like the effect so I'm going to change
the width of each item dynamically so
that the width is equal to the
proportion of the total budget that
could be assigned so like I said I know
that's not obvious but let's see what it
does when I come back and reload now if
I give some money to the developers you
can see those lines for everyone else
get smaller to represent the fact that
there's not as much money left for them
and if I use all the money up then you
clearly the salespeople can't have any
at all and I quite like this design
because if I decided that I do want to
give some money to sales I have to make
a decision about who I'm taking the
money away from so the developers are
being a bit greedy right now so let's
take some money away from them not too
much though and that leaves a little bit
left that we can hand over to the
salespeople ok so I think that's quite a
nice UI but we could do a little bit of
other stuff as well at the moment we
still got the problems that you could
leave some money or allocated which is
kind of stupid so how can we stop that
well let's add
save button for when you're finished and
we'll say that you're not allowed to
save until you've allocated all the
money so down as well I'm here I'm gonna
add a button which I'll spell correctly
and I'll write save as the caption and
I'm gonna say that this button will be
disabled if the remaining amount is
greater than zero so it's only enabled
if there's no money left to be allocated
let's check that work shall we so you
can see this button is grayed out right
now
but once I a liqu ate all that money as
soon as I do it pops in and you're now
allowed to save or it's disabled it's
enabled disabled enabled okay great
so it works we've managed to build
ourselves a little budget allocation you
are okay right what are the points that
I'm trying to make by doing that my
point is to give you a basic sense of
the Blazer programming model so what
you've seen is that we can use normal C
sharp code we can use normal HTML markup
and thanks razo we can mix them together
in a very natural and productive kind of
way we get full type safety everywhere
and generally we have a good time the
other major thing about the programming
modeling blaze with have not shown you
yet is how we can package different bits
of functionality up in reusable
components and nest them together and
I'm not going to do that just now
because I think you've seen enough and I
want to move on to some different and
possibly slightly cooler stuff ok so
you've just seen us building an
application that was running on the
server just then that was a server-side
blazer application let's have a go at
moving on to a bigger application now
and this time we're going to run it on
web assembly and along the way I'm gonna
show you some features that we've not
actually shipped or in some cases even
implemented yet just so you can get a
bit of a sense of where we're going with
this and hopefully get excited about
things over the next six months ok so
what's the scenario for our new
application well I thought it would be
kind of fun to do something that's not
meant to run in a normal web browser
because you know we do normal browser
stuff all the time what about we do
something that's meant to run on a
specialized piece of hardware and the
idea I came up with which is not that
exotic is the following
are these commonplace in Australia I
have no idea honestly they're fairly
common in the UK ok so people are
shaking their heads alright so if you've
not seen these before these are quite
widespread in the supermarkets in the UK
I think I've seen them in the United
States as well and the idea is that when
you go shopping you don't necessarily
after you filled your trolley up want to
go and stand in line and wait for
someone to scan all the items that's
kind of dull so when you walk into the
shop you may find that there's this big
Bank of devices near to the entrance and
you can walk over and you can pick one
of them up and it turns on and you take
it with you as you're walking around the
store and it's a really cheap little
mobile thing that probably runs some old
version of Android but it's pretty you
know it's adequate for this scenario and
while you're walking around each time
you want to buy something you scan it
its barcode and the device shows you a
list of all the stuff that you've got on
your trolley and what the total price of
it is so you can keep track of your
spending and when you've eventually
finished filling up your trolley you
don't have to go to a normal checkout
line you just go to this special payment
area where you scan your order onto the
machine and then it lets you put your
card in pay for it and you walk out and
you didn't have to line up so that's
saving you a better time ok so what
we're gonna do for the next 20 minutes
is build some of the UI that would run
on the device itself and hopefully as we
go I'll be able to illustrate some of
the benefits of using Blaser in general
and in particular some of the benefits
of running it on webassembly
ok so I'm gonna change over to a
different solution that I've been
working on because couldn't really do
this entirely from scratch during this
talk and in this solution you'll see
that we've got a few projects but we're
only going to focus on two of them right
now the client one and the server one so
the server which I'm just going to start
over right now so a start project and
run that that's my applications back-end
server and that is going to be the thing
that knows about all the inventory data
for the supermarket that's got the
database of products and it knows all
the prices and things like that because
we couldn't really get that much data
onto the little clients and then the
client project which I'm also going to
run in a minute is a blazer webassembly
application and you'll see in there that
we've got all the normal C sharp and
razor files things like that and that's
going to run inside the browser so let's
get that to start up in my browser now
ok so when that comes up you'll see we
get blazer Mart and when I'm going to
get in development I'll probably mostly
keep it in this landscape kind of shape
but actually
so from my picture before when you run
and get on a real device it's probably
going to be more of this sort of
portrait orientation but let's not worry
about the difference it won't really
affect us very much let's think about
what a user could do with this
application well the only thing we
really want them to be able to do is to
scan their groceries as they go around
so I've got a barcode scanner right here
and I've got various items of groceries
so let's see what happens if I try to
scan this tin of beans I scan it and
you'll see an item pops up in my UI and
a little footer thing appears below that
so how did that work let's have a look
at some of the code inside this
application okay so we've got this
component here called app dot racer and
that is the route component for my
application you construct your
application whatever you want but it's
probably going to be a fairly deep
hierarchy of components that you mostly
create yourself with some built-in
components and for this one I've got a
header section at the top and in there
I've got this search box and that's the
thing that deals with responding when
you use the barcode scanner it also just
lets you type stuff as well and as you
can see I've got a sort of autocomplete
type thing going on there you wouldn't
really have that on the actual device
but it's just helpful during development
to be able to type as well okay so
that's my search box at the top and then
below that I've got my main section and
just like we did in the budget UI we're
using a for each loop and we're saying
for each one of the things that's in
your car will display a cart row display
component which I've also implemented
and below that we've got an if test that
says if you've got something in your
cart then we'll display this footer so
you remember that we didn't have the
footer there when we first came but
after I scan something the footer
dynamically appeared that's just because
this if check here switched from being
false to true okay very good so it seems
like we're in a good place here but
obviously this application is not
finished because among other reasons it
doesn't display real product information
right now it just says fake product why
does it do that well let's see what
happens when you scan something it calls
this handle item chosen method and that
is defined down here and if I follow the
definition to that we'll be able to see
my domain model classes now you may be
thinking what on earth is an e well an e
is a European article number that's an
industry standard thing and it is
literally just the number that's printed
at the bottom of the barcode so that
uniquely identifies my products and I'm
passing the EAN into my domain type
where it's going to do some stuff what
does it do
well it's a normal C shop class and it's
got various bits of logic that I need
like if you've already got one of these
in your cart then we're going to
increment the quantity rather than
adding a separate row and if you don't
then we're going to look up the product
details from the back end I'm not really
interested in showing you that right now
I am interested in showing you this this
is the method that's going to try and
actually talk to the server or it should
do but it doesn't do anything like that
right now currently it just waits for
one second and then returns this fake
message that's why we're getting this
fake product thing so I want to actually
get some real data from the back end now
so how can I do that
well one really natural and obvious way
that you could do this is by making an
HTTP request to the backend and asking
it to give you a JSON description of the
product data and of course you can do
that that works really naturally that's
the standard way of doing these kinds of
things not just in Blaser but with most
other client technologies and that's
absolutely fine but there are some
drawbacks to fetching JSON over these
arbitrary unstructured URLs one of them
is that JSON is not a very efficient
format for data transfer over the
network
it's very verbose it's not very
efficient also Jason can only represent
JavaScript data so you're limited to the
kind of level of precision of stuff
that's available for things like numbers
in JavaScript another issue with it is
that it's all very loosely typed not
just the data itself but also the URLs
that you're making requests to if you
make a request to a certain URL how do
you know that there's even anything
listening for that URL what if they
change their schema in some way it's all
very much a sort of best efforts
unstructured kind of thing so we might
wonder is there a more modern
alternative to any of this that might be
a little bit more robust and the answer
is yes you are there's loads of things
people have come up with all kinds of
ideas over the years but one of these
ideas that's really started to get a lot
of traction in the last year or so is
something called G RPC or Google's
remote procedure call
and that is something that allows us to
say well let's not transfer data
sorry not less trans let's not transfer
JSON let's transfer a more efficient
compact payload and we'll do so in a
very strongly typed way so we'll get a
clear descriptor a formal machine
readable description about what services
are available at a certain endpoint and
so we'll know for sure that we're
calling the right thing and it can all
be type checked so the asp net core team
you'll be happy to know has been doing
quite a bit work during the 300 release
to ensure that we've got excellent
support for G RPC on the server and if
you want to learn loads about that
there's a talk by James over there
tomorrow where he'll be going into loads
of cool details about it but what I want
to do just now is make use of it okay so
what have I got to do in order to use
that to form a blazer client-side
application well firstly I should point
out to you that G RPC is not normally
usable from inside a browser because it
requires HTTP to natively and various
other things but there is a flavor of G
RPC called G RPC web that is usable by
web applications and that's not in the
box with a spinet called 3 however it's
quite easy to add support for using a
third party package and that's what I've
done here and if you want to see how
I've done that you can get the code for
this demo after the talk and have a look
at it yourself
the second thing you need to know is
that to define these services we use
these special files called proto files
and I've got one on the server right
there
inventory doc proto and if I open that
up you'll see this is a description of
what data endpoints I can call and at
the moment I've only got one it's called
autocomplete and that's the thing that
my client calls when I start typing into
this text box at the top to get the
autocomplete data but I want to add a
new one that returns product information
so I am going to add the definition of a
new service called product details and
it takes this particular type of request
in this type of response and I haven't
defined those yet so let me define my
request and my response types and you'll
see that the request is the client sends
an e am to the server the article number
and the server is going to reply just by
giving you a single product and this is
the definition of a product of here ok
so I want to now
and implementation for that where should
I put the implementation well one of the
nice things that the tooling does for us
if you're using this on a SP nut core is
that code generates a base class for you
here's my inventory service on the
server and inherits from inventory base
which is generated from that proto file
and it's got virtual methods on it that
you can override so if I type override
you'll see we've now got the product
details
to override and fill in the actual
implementation for our service and I can
do that pretty straightforwardly my
implementation will look like this I
need to make that async
so we'll first wait for a minute just
cuz otherwise you know it's too fast and
you can't even see what's going on and
then we will make a look-up inside our
database on the server to find that
particular product by its ID and we'll
return that back to the client so that's
all I really need to do right now I'll
restart my server with that updated
logic right next thing how can I consume
it in my Blaser application well inside
my domain model class cart here I've got
something called an inventory client and
if you're wondering where that comes
from I will show you if I show you
inside my project file I've got this
item down at the bottom called protobuf
and I've wired it up to the same proto
file that lives inside my server project
and I'm telling the tooling that I want
it to generate a client for me so that
will build it will automatically create
for me a nice strongly typed way of
accessing those services on the server
and that's what this inventory clone is
so if I look at the methods on there you
can see I've got autocomplete and I can
call it and you may be wondering okay
where's the product details one that I
just created and the answer to that is
well I haven't recompiled yet so it
hasn't refreshed so let me just quickly
recompile and when I have recompiled
then we'll try doing that again like
this and now you'll see that as well as
autocomplete we've also got product
details that we can call and we know
what type of data that's going to accept
and return so I'll just drop in my
actual logic that I want here which is
pretty straightforward we'll take that
article number we'll build it into a
request send it to the server and it's
going to give us back a product right
let's see if this actually works shall
we
I'll come back to my browser right
now and I will try to scan these beans
again and what do we get this time we
get beans so it does actually work what
else will I need on my shopping well I
think I would like to have some
chocolate and I'm working on a recipe
for this novel dessert so I'm also gonna
need some wasabi but my recipe needs a
little bit more wasabi just to really
bring out the flavor I make the best
desserts okay so what if we just
achieved well we've got our blazer
application running on webassembly
inside the client and we've been able to
take advantage of some of the new
features that are going in 2's peanut
core 3 or have gone in such as the
ability to use strongly-typed
services between a client and a server
and a very efficient data interchange
format and you can learn more about G
RPC tomorrow but let's move on the next
thing I want to show you is another
thing that we haven't shipped yet but
exists in prototype form and this is to
do with testing obviously an important
subject for any developer and it's
something that we've really had in our
minds in the very beginning of Glaser
one of our design goals that we've
always had is that you should be able to
write tests in a really easy satisfying
and reliable way but at the moment we've
not really got that at the moment if you
want to test your blazer components you
can write a unit test for them but it
doesn't really seem to achieve very much
because it's really hard to observe the
output of rendering your component how
do you even render it it's not clear
what you would do the other thing that
you can do today is use something like
browser automation using a tool like
selenium and that's something that we do
a lot on the team on asp net core we use
a lot of selenium stuff to test that the
products we're building actually work so
we've got a lot of experience and what
we find is that although it's great that
your tests can be really high level and
expressive you know you can express
things in terms of automating clicking
inside the browser and observing the
state of the dom corresponding to
certain CSS selectors that's all good we
like that then negative side of it tends
to be that these tests can be a bit slow
because they involve launching an actual
browser process for each test and unless
you're very careful they can be
unreliable you really have to know what
you're doing to avoid accidentally
depending on random details of the
timing of the renderer
and so if you're not careful you end up
having tests that are a bit flaky so
what we want is the best of all worlds
we want the ability to write high-level
expressive tests in terms of clicks and
CSS selectors and such but we want to
run them without running any actual
browser we want them to have the same
speed and robustness as native dotnet
unit tests so let me give you an example
by showing you the prototype that we're
working on at the moment this is
something you can try out today although
we haven't shipped it so I've got this
other project here called laser mark
test and if we look in there you'll see
I've got some unit tests the first one
is this and what this is going to check
is that when the application first comes
up there's nothing in your car makes
sense right so how it works is it starts
by getting an instance of the app
component and if you remember app is
this thing my root component here I
could write tests about individual sub
components but I just wish to write a
test about my real component I can do
that I can do what I like so what I'm
going to do is mount an instance of my
app component and then I'll check that
if we search for all the cart items that
it's rendered will find that there
aren't any it's an empty set okay that
should make sense next thing we're going
to check is that when you do add
something to your cart initially it
shows up as loading so what we're doing
here is again we're mounting an app
component and we're doing about funky
stuff to mock the data access layer the
G RPC service to capture any requests
that it's going to make which allows it
to make requests and then the next thing
we're going to do is simulate doing what
this barcode scanner does so if you were
wondering what the barcode scanner
actually does is it emulates a keyboard
it emulates typing so when I scan
something what that actually does is it
types the EAN into that input for in the
top right of my UI and then it presses
the enter key which submits the form so
I can simulate doing the same thing from
my test by typing into the input and
then submitting that form and then I can
hopefully do an assertion that says if
we now look for all the cart items we'll
find that there is one and the text on
it is loading and then the final test
here goes a step further and that checks
what happens when they serve a response
so again we're doing a bit of funky
stuff with mocking to say that when the
server returns a response
if the response is this product which
has got a name of something cool then
when we look in the UI we'll see that
still there's one item in the cart and
this time the text on it has changed to
something cool and we've got the right
price okay let's run these tests shall
we they're normal dotnet unit tests so
they can run anywhere that you run
donald normal donate unit tests you can
run them on the command line you can run
them from the yes so I'm gonna run these
three tests in vs right now I'm just
compiling it and then hopefully they
will start running and they will all
pass and you saw that it was basically
instant to on all of them because
there's no browser this is just running
in process as a unit test okay right
given that we've got this technology
that gives you some new possibilities
for how you do your development one of
those possibilities is you could build
your components using a kind of
test-driven development process if you
want to and I'm not trying to say that
you should all you must use TDD when
you're building blazer components all
I'm trying to say is that you can you
can use whatever test methodology you
want and the technology should be there
to support you doing it in whatever way
you like so let's have a go at building
a bit of functionality and we will do it
in a test-driven style just to get a
neck sense of whether that's nice or
horrible and the functionality I want to
build is this remove item button in the
bottom left there so let's say I've
decided that I don't really need the
chocolate for my recipe at all I want to
remove it how can I remove it well I'll
tell you how this does work in the
actual supermarket's in the
supermarket's they don't let you just
tap on the screen to remove stuff and I
suppose the reason for that is that you
might tap the wrong thing and that get
really confused or maybe you
accidentally tapped the expensive thing
and remove it and then don't pay for it
so what they want is for you to do
something a little bit of a more obvious
direct and physical action to show that
you're really removing the thing that
you want to and presumably this CCTV
security people can watch that you seem
to be doing the right thing and so what
they do is they force you to scan the
items out of your car in the same way
that you scanned it in so what I want to
happen is when I click on the remove
item button and one the application to
switch into a kind of remove mode where
it prompts me to scan something to
remove it and then when I scan it does
remove it and we switch back to the
normal
so that's quite a complicated UI flow
there and I think I would feel better if
I had some tests showing that I've
implemented that in the right kind of
way so let's build that in a sort of TDD
style I'll start by adding a little
outline for my unit test here it's
called can remove item and we'll start
by simulating being in the same state as
before where we've got one item in the
cart and the next observation I want to
make is that initially there isn't any
remove items overlay that covers the
screen so when I do implement this I'm
going to create an overlay that fills
everything up and it's going to have
this CSS class and I'm just checking
right now that it's not there by default
so let's run that test and see if it
passes do we think it should pass any
opinions yeah should Paskus there isn't
a note remove overlay and it does go
green we're all good now following the
kind of TDD process I'm going to keep
adding assertions until this starts
failing so men next assertion is going
to be that there should be a something
that's got the CSS class of remove item
and I'm going to click it and when I do
click it I should see that the overlay
that wasn't there before is there now
it's now not null and in fact there
should be some text inside it that says
scan an item to remove well let's run
that now and this time we should expect
it to fail because obviously we haven't
implemented that yeah so that runs and
indeed it does fail but does it give us
a clear explanation of why it failed
well let's find out it's kind of
difficult to read on such a tiny tiny
screen but if we scroll across we can
see it says the element does not have an
event handler for the event on click OK
so it's failing here is trying to click
remove item but it says no sorry that
thing doesn't even listen for clicks so
this makes no sense
and it dies all right so that's correct
because my button remove item doesn't
have any click handler so let's add one
shall we will say on click equals enter
remove mode that's the name of a method
which I haven't implemented yet so that
would be a compiler error right now
let's put in an implementation for that
method okay so my method is going to do
a very simple thing all it's going to do
is it's going to set a flag to true is
in remove mode
and I better define that flag so we'll
have a bull bull not a bowl called in
remove mode and that is going to be
common true okay now we want to display
this overlay whenever that bull is true
so we can put in a little bit more
markup here that says if we're in remove
mode will have this overlay and it'll
contain this content you're probably
wondering what overlay actually is is
this some kind of built in thing no it
is not
it's something I've defined in my
application it's quite straight forwards
here's the overlay component all it does
is it renders this div with a certain
CSS class which I've styled to fill up
the screen and it just sticks inside
there whatever content you've passed to
it and the content I am passing to it in
this case is this paragraph tag which
displays scan and item to remove right
let's run the test again and see if it
goes green this time do we think it will
no one's really committing I hope it
does let's see what happens yes it does
good we've successfully made the remove
overlay appear
well let's carry on with our little test
process now now I want to simulate what
happens if I scan an item while I'm in
the remove mode so I'm gonna say just
like before I'm gonna simulate the
scanner typing into that box a certain
EAN and it's the same number that we
added before and once we've done that
since we're in remove mode the cart
should change it wasn't empty before but
it should become empty now when we
search for the cart items that search
should now be empty and the remove
overlay should also go away okay let's
run our test and see if we've done our
job correctly the answer is we are not
finished yet we cannot go home for the
day the reason this time is if we follow
the link at the bottom the assertion
that's failing is this one the assert
are empty okay so we scanned the item
but it didn't get removed well that's
not surprising
since we didn't put in any logic to make
it get removed so let's do that well say
if we are is if we are in the remove
mode then we'll do something and if
we're not we'll do what we did before
and there we go
all right so if we are in the remove
mode we're going to tell the cart that
we want it to remove this item
okay so hopefully the item should
actually get removed now let's run our
test one more time and see if we're done
and we can go and show our product to
our customers let's find out any
opinions oh it didn't pass why didn't it
pass what's wrong still let's find out
let's scroll down and we'll click the
link and it seems that the assertion
that fails now is this one is because
the remove overlay is still on the
screen we forgot to make it go away
so we'll go back over here and we'll say
after you've scanned the item we'll set
is in remove mode to false and hopefully
that will now give us the behavior we
need and our test should hopefully go
green so we build and we run it again
and now all four tests are green we're
good we're happy and I don't even need
to run it in the browser because we're
totally confident it works right but I'm
sure you actually do want to see it
working so let's try it I'll reload and
I'm going to add a couple of things to
my car I'll get some Oh I didn't
actually focus right so we've got some
chocolate and we've got some beans and
then we decide we don't really need that
chocolate at all
so I'll click the Remove and you'll see
we get the overlay and now scan my
chocolate again and the chocolate goes
away and the functionality does work in
the way that we thought it did all right
cool so that is a prototype unit testing
system for Blazer components which
hopefully gives you the same sort of
expressiveness that you get with browser
automation combined with the sort of
speed and robustness of regular dotnet
unit tests now that's not something
we've shipped it's a prototype
hopefully we'll build something like
that I'm not promising it's going to be
exactly that but we'll make this
something like this into an actual
product over the next six months or so
okay let's move on third and final thing
that I'm going to show you something
that we've not got baked in yet but it's
quite important and cool and that is to
do with progressive web applications
speed ugly ways like I said we don't
have anything for this in the box right
now but it is something you can write
your own code for to add some
interesting capabilities to your
application and this allows me to
illustrate some of the benefits of
running on blazer in webassembly
specifically because that makes it a
true client-side application so you can
use all of the features that are
available to modern client-side web apps
so what kind of thing would
we want to do well one of the things
that PWA is a really good at is that
they can work even if you're offline and
that's actually very relevant for this
sort of scenario because if customers
are picking these devices up and walking
around with the shop with them well
presumably it's trying to use the
install Wi-Fi to do all this kind of
connectivity but Wi-Fi is not a hundred
percent robust what happens if at the
exact moment that someone picks this up
and starts trying to use it that it
doesn't manage to have a Wi-Fi
connection at that moment what kind of
customer experience are they going to
get if the device is offline when they
try to use it
well I'll simulate that I'll pretend
that I'm offline in my browser and I'll
press the button to start my application
and the customer experience is an error
message that just says you're not
connected which is not a cool experience
at all and our customers will not get a
good impression of us so what do we want
to do we want to add some offline
support to our application and because
this is a client-side app we can do it
using a serviceworker service workers
are something that's just a standard
browser feature and I'll show you how we
can do it right in my dub-dub-dub root
folder here I've got this file called
serviceworker dot j/s and this is
something that can be installed into the
browser for my application and it takes
charge of various things such as all the
network traffic between this site and my
server and you might be wondering first
of all hang on a minute why are you
writing this in JavaScript I thought the
whole point here was that we were going
to be writing stuff in dotnet well the
answer today is that service workers
don't run within your application at all
they run in a completely separate
context I can't write it in dotnet
because there is no Donaire there well
theoretically I could use the Service
Worker JavaScript to boot up an instance
of the mono web assembly runtime and
then run some dotnet code inside a yeah
I absolutely could but I really think
that would be crazily overkill because a
typical Service Worker tends to be about
30 or 40 lines of code so I really think
don't think we need to do all that and
if you're wondering well how would I
write something like this how do I know
how to write a serviceworker file the
answer to that from me is basically well
you don't you don't really have to write
this yourself because service workers
are just boilerplate things they just do
send standard stuff so
if you want a service worker just go on
the internet and search for Service
Worker boilerplate or Service Worker
cookbook I think that's what I did and
you can just find various standard
service workers that people have read
and I've got one here that implements a
certain version of offline support so
the offline logic this users is it tries
to do all the requests through the
network if there is a network connection
but if it does that and it finds that
you don't have a network connection then
it will fall back on serving cached data
into the browser and hopefully that
means things will work when you're
offline so I'm going to install this
Service Worker into my application and
you do that by adding this little call
into your index.html saying browser hey
using your serviceworker api i would
please like you to register this
serviceworker dot j/s ok so i've done
that now and so now back in the browser
if I look on my console when I reload
you see we get this message
installing serviceworker so that sounds
promising and once that's installed it
takes charge of all the network traffic
and so now I've got it to log all of the
mess all the network requests that it
sees are happening and because I'm
online it's letting all those requests
be resolved via a network course but
because this is installed as well that
means I don't even need to be online so
if I go back to simulating being offline
again this time when I user starts to
use the application and they don't have
Wi-Fi do they get an error message this
time the answer is no the application
just comes up and it starts to work so
that's a pretty cool improvement but if
you're thinking a couple of steps ahead
you might be thinking well Steve you
think you're very clever don't you
making that work offline but it's not
clever at all in fact it's stupid and
rubbish because when the user starts
walking around the shop they'll start
trying to scan products and you still
can't reach the server can you so it's
not going to do anything useful at all
well ok let's see what happens shall we
so this is still my dotnet application
running inside the browser it's still
going to run all its own logic need to
focus it still gonna run all its own
logic so you know it's going to try
adding stuff to the list and I can do
that as much as many times as I want but
you're right we don't have a network
connection so we can't reach the server
but you know it's really running our
actual net
code so we can put in whatever kind of
retry logic we want and I've got a
little bit of logic in there so it's
retrying and when our customer walks
into a bit of the shop that's got Wi-Fi
connection then let's see what happens
due to all the retrying logic all the
stuff eventually finishes and it
populates all the data that it wasn't
able to get before so that's not a
miracle it doesn't allow network traffic
to work even with no connection but it
does give us a reasonable level of
resilience to temporary network outages
which i think is perhaps the best thing
that you could possibly hope for with
this kind of application okay now what
other things can we do with a PWA well
another one of the fun tricks that PWS
can do is be installed into your
operating system so they can install
into your Start menu on Windows your
dock on Mac or if you're on a mobile
device iOS or Android there can be
installed with a little icon on your
home screen and then they don't appear
to run in a browser all they appear to
be their own application and that's a
good thing for us because when our
customers are using these devices we
don't want them to think they're using a
web browser cos they probably start
using it for some completely unrelated
purpose so we want them to just see this
as being you know and regular native app
that's the only thing that they can run
on that device it's very easy using PWA
api's to make your application
installable all you need is a manifest
file and i've got one here it's very
simple it's gives the name of the
application an icon and some colors and
I just need to register that in my
index.html so I'm going to add this link
tag right here that points to this
manifest file let's see what effect that
has now before I reload I want you to
watch very carefully these icons on the
top right up here you see I've got two
icons
we've got zoom and we've got favourites
but when I reload because of my manifest
hopefully a third icon will now become
available
what's this extra little plus thing
that's appeared well that now says
install blazer Mart and the user or your
sis ID mineral ever can now install this
application onto the device and if they
do that it no longer shows up in the
browser but it now pops up in its own
window without any other browser UI
around it but it's still the real
application and it
and the user can do things like find it
on their Start menu so if I start
searching you'll see I've got blazer
Mart here that's installed click that
pops up in its own window and it's still
the real thing it's gonna do all the
stuff that it was doing before okay very
good so hopefully that gives you a sense
of some of the nice things that we can
do with a blazer application that's
running on webassembly what we've done
is we've been able to use G RPC to get
strongly-typed data access with an
efficient efficient network traffic
we've been able to write some unit tests
in quite a nice expressive way and we've
been able to take advantage of running
inside the client to use some of these
PW our features ok now let's change the
subject slightly now and let's think
about this some slightly broader topics
I want to think about all the ways that
we can run a blazer application you may
remember from the start of this talk
that we had this slide before which
talked about client side blazer and
server side blazer well let's just think
about these two models a little bit and
why you would choose between each of
them in fact can you even use these are
these released and supported yet well
when it comes to server side blazer that
has been shipped already that is part of
the espenak core 3 release that's
already been out for about a month so
that is fully released fully supported
ready for your production use today
client side blazer or blazer webassembly
on the other hand that is still in
preview we've committed to shipping it
but we haven't done so yet and we've got
a targeted release date of May next year
so you've got about 6 months to wait
until that becomes a production
supported thing it has been in preview
for a long time many many people have
been using it successfully already many
people have been putting it into
production already even though we tell
them not to but it's up to you you can
go and have a go with that and hopefully
you'll find that it's nice and
successful but again I want to emphasize
what I see as being the main point here
which is that it's flexible if you build
some application using blazer then you
can run it as client-side you can run it
as server-side you can change between
them you can use birth at once whatever
it's up to you you get that kind of
flexibility but still you might be
thinking all right thanks for the
flexibility but what do
even wonderful why would I use one or
the other well some of the benefits of
using client-side laser are that because
it's a true client-side application it
will be able to work offline it's truly
in the browser it can use all the PWA
features and it's just there you know
running on the client it means that
you're not having to spend any of your
server resources on the CPU and RAM
needed to run it it's just there in the
browser and because it's right there
when it wants to update the UI it does
so with zero latency so you can write
really really high performance rapidly
updating you eyes that update instantly
inside the browser that another cool
thing about blades are running on the
client is that when it comes to
deploying it as far as your web server
is concerned it's just static files you
don't you can serve it from an ASP
nightcore application but you don't
actually need any dotnet on the server
all if you wanted to you could serve it
from a node.js application you could put
it on a CDN you could serve it from as
your static web sites or something and
just to really prove that to you I've
deployed my blazer Mart application to
get hub pages you probably know github
pages is a thing that github gives you
that lets you deploy static sites and
here it is
so here's blazer Mart and you can see
it's running from this github do I owe
you RL but it's still the same
application that we had before it still
does all the same things that you
expected ok so that means we've got this
very very cheap and fast geographically
distributed hosting available very
easily ok that's good what about on the
other side then what are the benefits of
writing server-side Blaser well one of
the major drawbacks of client-side
blazer is that it does involve bringing
this dotnet runtime down into the
browser and at the moment the default
blazer application is two point four
megabytes transferred over the wire so
that's quite big we're working on making
it smaller but still it's quite big and
also it requires using the user CPU to
execute server-side laser on the other
hand is a thin client model so that's
putting all the load onto the server
instead which means that it's going to
work even on super low-end devices it's
going to load just about instantly even
own slower network connections and the
end users device doesn't have to do the
work to update the UI because the server
will do it ok now another cool thing
about server-side blazer is because your
code is on the server
you can do everything that server-side
dotnet core can do including things like
interact with arbitrary bits of hardware
on the server so imagine that you want
to do some super advanced GPU powered
machine learning thing well that will
work incredibly easily with suicide
laser you're already running on the
server you can just use whatever kind of
cloud based GPUs you want and it's all
just going to execute there and send the
results down to the browser wonderful
and you don't even have to disclose your
proprietary data models it all just
stays up there in the cloud so that's
another major one of the benefits of
server-side Blaser of obviously the main
drawback to server-side laser is because
you're running in the cloud all of the
interactions are happening place
happening over the network so if there's
a lot of latency in the between the
client and the server end users will see
that latency so we recommend that for a
really good user experience you need to
distribute your servers such that each
user is within about 100 milliseconds of
round-trip time to the server okay right
so those are the current ways of running
a blazer application that's what we've
committed to ship so far but what about
further down the line are there other
ways that we can run blazer well if you
came to Ryan's talk this morning you
will have heard about the idea of blazer
and electron I'm not going to demo that
for you because that was already demoed
today but that allows you to take an
electron shell to run a blazer
application as a desktop application
without any webassembly involved so it's
using regular net core on the desktop to
render the application and use all of
the native OS features without being
limited by browser sandbox we haven't
committed to ship that but there is a
sample that you can use right now if you
want okay so that's three things why
have we got this blank space in the
bottom right well so far all the stuff
I've talked to you about so far uses web
based rendering but wouldn't it be
interesting if we could use the blazer
programming model but not render HTML
and CSS could we instead of rendering
that rendered native UI elements is that
even theoretically possible well we've
been doing a little collaboration with
the xamarin team to do an experiment on
this to see if we could build native
mobile apps for iOS and Android that
don't render web pages but actually
render native control
and I'm emphasizing this is super
experimental we don't even have a sample
to share with you but I'm going to show
you a little bit right of that right now
so you can get a sense of what that
would be like and give us some feedback
about how you feel about it so let's
have a look at this other application
called blaze a mobile app now thankfully
our friends on this Ameren team have
done most of this work for us so I
didn't have to do this but I can still
show it to you and feel cool about it
we've got this blaze a mobile app up
here which is a normal blazer
application containing C sharp and razor
files things like that and you can see
I've got a counter in it to-do list and
so on we've also got these two other
projects iOS and Android so I can run
this on either of those two operating
systems so let me show you this actually
running and I want to show you this
running on a real iPhone so hopefully
I'm going to be able to make my phone
screen pop up on the projector right now
there we go okay so this is a regular
iPhone that I've got and I've built this
plays a mobile application and deployed
it to my phone when I start out you'll
see we've got all the things that you
normally have in a traditional kind of
software demo such as we've got this
counter so I can click that and it
increments a few times we've also got a
to-do list because obviously everyone
has to have it to-do lists when they
build a new thing and then finally we've
got this calculator and it does actually
work so I can you know solve some math
problems great but the important thing
to emphasize here is this is not
web-based rendering this is not some
kind of web view this is rendering
native iOS elements and let's just see
another thing yep let's do some to-do
list things so let's say I want to do
some stuff okay what happens when I
press this Add button well we get ah we
get a to-do we haven't yet implemented
the to-do list okay so shall we go and
implement our to-do list right now well
let's see some of the code we've got in
here first let's look at this counter
thing if you've been doing any blazer
programming this will look very familiar
to you it's the same sort of thing where
we've got some markup and we've got some
c-sharp code and in our c-sharp code
we've got a current count and we're
displaying a label saying how many times
you've clicked it and we've got a button
that says when you click
we're going to run this method increment
count and that will obviously increment
the count and then blaze the knows how
to update the relevant part of the UI as
you can see this is not HTML I couldn't
use HTML here even if I wanted to
because that would involve them in some
kind of browser to render it and there
is no browser here this is just native
iOS widgets or elements whatever you
call them ok let's see this to do this
thing well what's the logic for to-do
list well we've got a list of to-do
items and we are going to render them
but we need to like the user type some
stuff in so I've got this string
property new text and I've got a text
area or an entry as its called
where we can type in some value for the
new text and then there's a button and
when you click it it calls add item and
currently that just displays this silly
message so let's put our real logic in
so we'll say we'll say to-do items dot
ad and we'll construct a new to-do item
and we'll populate the text on that to
be the new text and then we'll set the
new text back to be null so that we
clear out that text box okay we need to
do a bit more though so we still need to
actually display the items so just like
we've been doing all along we can use
normal blazer style coding patterns will
do a c-sharp for each loop for each item
in to-do items we are going to render
let's say a let's make that go away I
can't stand extra line breaks we'll make
a to-do item to-do list item going in
there and the item that we're going to
pass to it is the item from this loop
okay so that's pretty much all we need
but one last thing is I want to display
the number of items that I've still got
left to do today so I'm going to use
some normalcy Sharpe syntax to count up
how many things haven't been done yet so
we'll get the to-do items and we will
count all of the items such that the
item is not yet done ok let's check that
that builds does all right so I've got
deployed that version of my application
as well and so if we run this when we go
over onto the to-do list now let's let's
get some stuff and I'll hit add and it
does show up in the list let's get some
more stuff
a blazer and actually I can't be
bothered to type so let's just do this
autocomplete thing blazer is the time of
that time to come to see you yes that
makes sense alright so we've been able
to get a little to-do list to work and
you can see that I can toggle these
things and the numbers all up day
correctly because we're doing the normal
blazer programming patterns and
everything stays up today okay so let's
just stop that right then so that is all
we're gonna have time to do in this talk
I hope that's been of some interest to
you and giving you some ideas about
things you can do in your next
application if you want to learn a bit
more if you want to get started with
this stuff then go to this URL blazer
dotnet and that will take you to our
documentation which will give you
everything that you need to get started
and if you want any of the code or if
you want the slides from this talk then
you can go to that URL up there and that
I'll take you into the github repo
that's listed below and you can get this
stuff so I hope that's good for you
I hope you enjoyed it I hope that you
remember to evaluate on your way out
and most importantly I hope that you
have a superb rest of the conference
[Applause]